hey guys what's up this is andrew from
trendsenses.com so in this video i would
like to talk about tesla this is a stock
i'm following for some time we had some
crazy moves happening this week with
some news a strong volume
so let's analyze the situation i'm gonna
quickly go through the news and of
course go through the technicals and
show you my targets let's get into it
[Music]
alright so let's start quickly with the
news so you guys probably heard of that
already but let's say it again uh there
was a deal between hertz and tesla about
100 000 cars all right by the end of
2022 so this is around 10 of what tesla
is producing in one year so of course
this is a very big contract that is very
good for the company what happened to
ellen musk after that was that he just
became the richest man in the history
reaching uh you know
287 billion something close to 300
billion us dollars so he is far above
jeff pesos now so once again whenever
you have someone that is that powerful
of course
it will help him to run the company as
he desires all right because you know
money creates power and power creates
money you know so there is a virtuous
cycle in the fact that not only his
company is doing good but he is also
doing extremely good and can use this
energy to even give more strength to
tesla so i see only good things here now
let's have a look at the technicals
so
i've been covering the stock for maybe
one year and you can check my videos
here i was saying we're gonna go to 1000
we almost reached that then i was
talking about this false wave correction
that was expected to last a few months
it lasted around six months and then
here we had the breakout
so
this was to me
the first signal that we were bullish
and then here when we created this new
high
it was the confirmation that we're
starting the fifth wave
so
what can we expect from here i'm gonna
stay on what i told you guys which is
basically that we are doing a one two
three four five we completed the fourth
so we now have target for the fifths so
the targets are usually in this kind of
movement
the fifth wave
is going either to the 0.618
fibonacci projection of one plus three
or one to one or one to one point six
one eight so this gives us three levels
the first level is eliminated because
it's very close to all time high the
0.618 so it leaves us with two levels
1400
1900 let's call it two thousand so one
thousand five hundred roughly or two
thousand
four maybe june 22 so around six months
i think we're going to go there so we're
talking about 50 or 100
move up for this stock and
usually if we look at the past this kind
of of moves they develop in five waves
according to earlier to a theory
and we have some relations between uh
the length of each wave so here
what we can say is that we completed the
first wave that was uh the breakout wave
here one two three four five then pull
back to the breakout area here by the
way uh i gave you this alert guys on
discord then we started to do live
training only after so we didn't manage
to catch it uh maybe we're gonna get in
later after we started live trading but
uh there was here a very nice buying
opportunity that once again i gave you
guys
so i hope some of you are in this trade
and right now what can we expect so it's
pretty clear to me that the first wave
is complete
we corrected and we are doing the third
wave so as usual third waves are the
most impulsive so we're not surprised to
have i mean not surprised you're always
surprised when you see uh so strong
moves up but somehow if it needs to
happen it usually happens in the third
wave in which we are so right now we're
gonna start to we're gonna try to break
down this wave into five waves so one
two so we're on the third of the third
so this is what we can expect
i'm gonna give you the level of the top
of the third
of course
it's gonna be approximative but let's
try we don't have many tools here as we
are in
a noman's land it's the first time we're
trading around this levels we don't have
resistance
we don't have
many
levels that we can use to say all right
here there should be some sellers but
fib projections are a tool that is very
useful and that gives quite good results
so here one two three so i'm not sure
the third of the third is complete or
not
but we might expect one more pullback
all right on the short term so let's say
it's complete maybe to the 950 area okay
and then we should have one more move up
quickly before december i would say so
in the coming months i expect one
pullback and one strong move up
and in terms of level for the top of the
third the only thing we can do is just
look at the past and see
where this was usually going in the last
two moves up so the
third wave which was very explosive is
very much looking like the fifth wave
we're doing right now so let's use that
and see so here i'm gonna measure
okay the first
wave
okay and i'm gonna apply it to the
bottom of the second wave and i'm gonna
check
where the top of the third was so here
we can see that first wave was going
from 60
to
200 roughly then we corrected and here
the third wave that happened guys last
year
it was absolutely massive and it went to
the
three times 3.618
extension fibonacci projection level of
the first wave so let's do it here
because it's the only thing we can do
guys there is
no other way i mean otherwise you can
use some oscillator indicators like the
rsi
but it's going get uh overbought quickly
and it still can go higher so here if i
just use that
i have the 3.618 that is around 1340
so
visually it looks good this is roughly
what i would have put it and we have the
feed projection of the last move up that
is telling us that this third wave might
go to this level as well we have one
more method that we can use we can use
again the feed protection to one plus
three inside the third wave but we don't
know yet if the third is complete or not
and we don't know where the force wave
my bottom
so this is a bit too early actually to
do it won't give me
good results here i can still try okay
if we come back to the 900 area
it's not giving me anything that is in
line with what i already had
maybe something around 1400 if the if
it's a one-to-one relation so we have
this kind of area 1 300
1400 maybe 1 200 you know it's hard to
say but roughly we have a 20 30 or
40 move up to come in the coming month
this is what i'm saying so let's see if
this happens but if it does happen
then we would probably correct so the
correction would then last probably one
or two months so i think we're gonna be
bullish for the coming month then
correct and then go to the roughly 2000
level so this is my scenario let's see
how things happen but
it's looking pretty good to me here so
that's it for today i hope you guys
enjoyed this video and if you did please
don't forget to click on the sub like
and bell button so you're gonna be the
first to know when i upload anything new
and stay close to shore see you guys